so I am gonna take current suggestion
and I'm gonna consider this question and
if you're wondering yes you can do this
this like this setting out you can do it
in the exam it's fine because as you see
I'm gonna solve this and use that to
solve another question okay all right
now what would this mean what would this
mean think back to my equation before
right about what expenditures are and
what that equation actually signifies
okay what have I got here I suppose I've
got it backwards okay I've got something
that's growing at a certain rate then I
have a time and then I have a final
destination okay so this just makes
sense
I'll go something it starts off as a set
aside and then when you look at the Ray
right it's getting smaller
okay that's why I'm gonna get from four
and five to sixty nine twenty five to
sixty four hundred fifty-five and so
it's getting these ones as well as well
so I want to know this is the point of
my sub question right all right how long
I can you see Y is a long question it's
how long how long will that take me to
get to this this is the UM the final
amount that I'm interested in sorry you
have a zero okay all right now because
it's in the index right because it's a
question of time or how many watts if
you like which is it again the question
tomorrow that's why I rewrite it as a
lawyer okay
so how'd I do that what's a and is equal
to
log base 4 5 so again base becomes the
base okay and then here's our point no
one ok so you can see I've rewritten
them in a more meaningful way this is my
right is my final amount and this is the
time it's gonna take me okay now you can
rewrite this by the way do you know how
to prove the UM change of base rule
so now that I've established this let's
come back and solve the question shall
we
I'm I generally pick base aid okay for
one reason I have to write one listed up
and it's equivalent it's actually
equivalent in fact like wave um we just
got in a bit of a fuss over this on the
other you talk exams
this is unambiguous right when you see
log and there's no base provided it
could be base 10 if you like calculator
it's a bit dumb no one else ever use it
but it's attended us but you don't have
the base truth sorry that's not
ambiguous so someone's calculate now
what what decimal value to be absolutely
yet all right yeah I forgot okay yeah
yeah
correct
yeah that's exactly right um okay so
being that we could choose any base we
like whichever one will get us at this
point anyway
now what was the point what what did
doing this what did it solve okay think
back this is why I spent all that time
trying to explain you know what all of
these bits signify okay it means that
often time 20.6 three bla bla bla bla
bla
okay time periods okay that's my time
unit okay after that amount of time
that's when I get to exactly 0.01 that's
when I arrive okay I started it
something big and it's getting smaller
and smaller and smaller and after when I
get this many times smaller that's when
I get there
now look at the question what we
actually want to solve I want this thing
which is getting small and small - ah I
want it to be smaller than that right I
don't want to get there I need to go a
bit pasta okay which is why you can no
it's not the previous number if I said
any clues 20 what would that mean it's
getting smaller but I'd stop just short
I've gained there I think it's quite
quite per one one okay so you see how
understanding this is about time and
about how much something is growing or
in this case getting smaller okay that's
the key to understand therefore n has to
be greater than
21 is that make sense because it could
be 21 or in between 2 or 3 3 any of
those numbers will be fine because we've
gone past the tipping point if you're
like okay so so therefore 21 21 is the
actual on integer after this to do if we
did enough it's don't because said
20-point 700 if they didn't ask for an
integer right it's a bit tricky because
if they said okay what army what
specifically
exactly so it's like how do I pick one
so what you do is you have to say it's
you just have to provide the whole one
block right because if you say twenty
point six four I can say no I can get
one that's smaller than that but still
bigger than this number and I can play
this game forever
right so you actually put to leave this
if if it was not an integer
you'd have to leave it there that's what
you have to